ja also der harald martenstein hat vor
natürlich wieder visionär vorweg nehmen
was ich da sagen wollte das stichwort
gesetzt nämlich das stichwort steinzeit
meine damen und herren wir bewegen uns
jetzt zurück in die steinzeit des faust
rechts und der toxischen männlichkeit
ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich diesen
begriff einmal in den mund nehmen ohne
rot zu werden oder dass mir die zunge ab
fand aber was wir da gesehen haben
toxische männlichkeit bei den oscar
feiern und ich sage das als jemand der
ein ganz großer verein ist von will
smith ich habe gejubelt bei idea for
independence day also zusammen mit jeff
goldblum diesen todesmutigen piloten
spielte der die welt von der
außerirdischen bedrohung befreite und
was macht diese will smith gestern oscar
freuen sie haben sicher davon gehört
oder vorgestern ich habe die zeit
übersicht verloren chris rock der
moderator der ganzen feierlichkeiten hat
einen witz gemacht der die frau von will
smith betroffen und es ist ein
grenzwertiger witz und ich kann das auch
verstehen dass sie nicht amüsiert war
wie es mit allerdings hat gelacht dann
aber plötzlich geht dies will smith
ansatzlos auf die bühne und schmiert
diesen chris rock also voll eine runter
eine breitseite und das ist für mich als
ehemaliger land ok spielern linkes
mittelfeld mit grünen leibchen des
luzerner sc eine klare in go area das
ist ein grobes foul eine art
blutgrätsche eine mediale blutgrätsche
und da muss man den spieler im
wettbewerb sofort
disqualifizieren und man hätte ihm
diesen oscar den er dann noch gewonnen
hat den müsste man ihm jetzt entziehen
dem will smith das geht einfach nicht
das ist das falsche vorbild und noch ein
weiterer punkt kommt dazu wir haben in
den letzten jahren dieses hollywood also
einen scheinheiligen tempel der
selbsternannten pseudo moral ein
bisschen im stile von dem was er hat
marc stein erzählt hat gesehen die haben
sich auf jedes podest gestellt die haben
den früheren amerikanischen präsidenten
trump für jede deplatzierte
twitter-meldung also wirklich durch den
fleischwolf gedreht aber jetzt wenn
einer der dem das irgendwie den kopf
gestiegen ist dem andern eine runter
haut dann ist das eine art dann läuft
der show must go on das finde ich nicht
gut man müsste will smith den oscar
wegnehmen das ist nicht die art und
weise will man hier auftreten sollte
herr maschmeyer sollte man ihm den oscar
wegnehmen ich bin der meinung nein der
oscar ist eine ganz klare auszeichnung
für eine tätigkeit für einen film da der
eine hervorragende hauptrolle gespielt
es ist jetzt kein preis fürs lebenswerk
es ist keine straße nach ihm benannt
worden die academy berät ja noch ob sie
ihn zukünftig ausschließen wollen wenn
die live entschieden hätten wäre die
oscars bekommt das wird ja vorher
gewählt also die der umschlag ist ja
verschlossen das musste ja nun wir sind
glaube ich drei leute vorher wer welche
namen in welchem umschlag stehen das
halte ich nicht für gerechtfertigt ich
finde die reaktion der körperlichen
gewalt nicht gut gerade in der heutigen
zeit aber
ich kann etwas verstehen dass man auf
brauchst ich kann auch kritik ab
beleidigungen ab juni ab aber wenn es um
meine kinder geht oder meine frau und in
dem fall ist ja die frau von will smith
erkrankt und hat haarausfall und darüber
war dieser witz also dass er seine frau
verteidigt für nicht vom grundsatz gut
aber das ganze ohne körperliche gewalt
wäre geschickter und sogar nachhaltiger
völlig einverstanden wenn es denn so
eine auch böse gemeinte beleidigung
gewesen wäre aber diese chris rock ist
ja nicht ein bösartiges
für den zuschauer
gemacht hatte sagte ich begrüße alle
anwesenden will smith djg jej und damit
spielt der run auf die den haarausfall
das ist der viel mit demi moore wo sie
eine marien chor keiner für ihn gespielt
auch mit diesen hat sich also lustig
gemacht über das und ich glaube aber ich
weiß es nicht ich glaube dass chris rock
hier das nicht mit dieser bösartigkeit
gemeint hat das passt nicht zu seinem
charakter und ich glaube dass man das
problem hätte lösen können auch mit
einem verbalen spruch der hätte sich
nämlich entschuldigt und dass man hier
gleich raus geht wenn er ist das
wirklich aus gekostet hätte und das in
einer art und weise getan aprils mist da
kommst du noch dazu hat ja am anfang
noch mitgelacht also möglicherweise
hatte gar nicht gemerkt wie sehr das die
freie verletzter darum war das ein akt
von nachholen der redlichkeit in
anführungszeichen
daneben steige sei ja manchmal bei
sportlern fußballspiel eishockey böse
fouls wo die hinterher sagen ich war so
im rausch ich möchte noch etwas zu
seiner verteidigung sagen oder alle die
dort sind nominiert sind ich ahne wie
viel liter blut durch den körper fließt
bekomme ich jetzt meinen ersten oscar
oder nicht da ist ein adrenalin druck im
normalen leben hätte mit gelacht und
gesagt pass auf wollte sich doch jetzt
bei meiner frau entschuldigen das ist
eine sonne
bei unserer beherrschen um ein detail
aus meinem familienalltag zu verraten
meine frau war begeistert von will
smiths ich auch und hat gesagt dass sie
sich von mir wenn sie mal öffentlich
beleidigt wird die gleiche reaktion
wünscht also die stimme der toxischen
weiblichkeit schon mal will ich würde
das nie waren warum
ich bringe ich bin körperlich also was
scheint also bei weitem nicht so fit wie
will smith ich kann das nicht machen
aber ich muss roger köppel in einem
punkt wirklich beipflichten wenn das
jemand aus in einem anderen lager und am
anderen kontext gemacht hätte irgend so
eine reaktionäre republikaner der würde
wahrscheinlich bis zum ende seines
lebens keine sonne mehr
das ist ja das ist er wer das ist halt
der liebe will smith und wer weiß
gewesen wäre wäre ich noch bei mehr als
einer werden gute er ist einer von den
guten und da darf er das machen es ist
natürlich das war ein scherz was sie
eingangs gesagt habe als ich meine das
zitat war echt aber es ist es ist nicht
richtig gewesen was er da gemacht hat
aber ihm den oscar abzuerkennen
das ist so nicht das wäre so eine
cancelled culture reaktion finde ja dass
apple auch insgeheim dass es diese
toxische männlichkeit gar nicht so
schlecht findet vielleicht hat ja in ihm
natürlich alleine wie sie reden über
hollywood
im letzten jahr so wenig zuschauer wie
nie zuvor also es musste auch was
passieren und vielleicht gab es ja auch
ein drehbuch aber das war ja ein scherz
das möchte ich eigentlich nur so am
rande erwähnt haben ich habe eigentlich
auch den ganzen tag gestern sehr viel
sympathie mit dieser toxischen
männlichkeit gehabt mit will smith bis
20 uhr 13 glaube ich in einem öffentlich
rechtlichen sender die tagesnachrichten
geschaut und neben mir saß mein
neunjähriger sohn so und dann musste ich
natürlich zu recht sagen nee das macht
man nicht und das war der moment wo ich
sagen stimmt wo es mir was du gemacht
hast dann ist vielleicht also muss die
übertragung das hätte noch besser
hingekriegt oder toll wenn du das auch
für mich machen ist aber sobald die
kinder dabei setzen muss man sagen nein
geht überhaupt nicht und das war der
moment wo ich denke mein team hat
toxische möglichkeit aufgegangen wäre
also in dem fall würde ich sagen geht
ein bisschen meine sympathien roger
köppel obwohl ich dafür ihre
einschätzung auch verstellt staune hier
ein bisschen über diese unterdrückten
gewalt sehen sich die in der runde
gewesen für friedliche koexistenz von
nicht mit dieser ohrfeigen kommt unsere
quoten sind so dass wir das gar nicht
braucht
ein wirkliches problem so und hier nicht
wenn wir mehr auf diese auf diesen akt
doch mal also wenn wir noch mal darauf
zurückkommen also zum beispiel ich bin
bei herr maschmeyer ich finde er soll
nicht in oskar zurückgeben und ich würde
sogar noch weiter gehen warum wird denn
immer jede menschliche regung jaja die
fehler gemacht er hat sich dann auch
entschuldigt und dann hat eine ohrfeige
verteilt also es ist nicht gut aber ich
habe jetzt gerade überlegt ob ich jetzt
meiner schwester die ist aber jetzt auch
schon über 20 sagen würde dass ich das
so schlimm finde ich finde es nicht so
schlimm eigentlich an der ritterlichkeit
bewiesen und was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen ist nicht nur gewalt ist gewalt
die körperlich ausgeführt wird worte
kann auch gewalt sei man aber jetzt
schauen sie wahrscheinlich jahre sagt
mein sohn vor der sehr guter schüler ist
aber nie wir uns mal an indem wir uns
mal vor oder überlegen wir uns seine
lehrerin würde ihm vor der klasse sagen
in den letzten arbeit hast du leider nur
eine vier oder fünf geschrieben und er
würde aufstehen und hingehen und ihr
eine kleine im vergleich angriff erklärt
die lehrerin feilte eltern auch hätte
jetzt die eltern beleidigt von ihrem
sohn ja aber auch dann wird und dann hat
er gesagt das darfst du nicht über mein
vater sagen und dann hätte er vielleicht
irgendwie reagieren und kleider lehrerin
einen das macht ja ein schüler bei einer
lehrerin wie alt ist der junge mann
so der wird ja seine lehrerin kaum
frauen also körperliche gewalt geht gar
nicht ich habe ein bisschen verständnis
für die überreaktion und weil es quasi
zur verteidigung der psychischen gewalt
die er empfunden hat die seiner frau
gegen die fahrzeuge gar nicht empfunden
ich glaube die frau war einfach nicht
organisiert er hat noch gelacht und ich
du musst dich aus führungskraft herr
maschmeyer wenn sie sind ein super
erfolgreich der ist keine
führungskreisen ist ein kredit oder
künstler musik was ist denn das für ein
gewalt relativismus in dieser runde ich
bin da eine richtige etwas
testosteronhaltigen runde gegen menschen
nein nein nein aber ich bin wirklich du
musst dich im griff haben wenn zinedine
zidane in diesem berühmten fußballspiel
den italiener mit dem kopfstoß getroffen
und weil auch beleidigt worden ist dann
hatte auch sein eigenes seine
vorbildfunktion massiv ramponiert obwohl
man sich vorstellen kann was da auf den
fußball aber da bin ich der meinung
seine dank sie wären es hätten beide vom
platz fliegen müssen wenn meine mutter
[ __ ] bezeichnet wird und da ist ja nun
in einem weltmeisterschafts endspiel
auch adrenalin das ist ja werde ich
weltmeister oder nach der wahl hätten
die heide vom platz fliegen sollte war
diese können auch verletzlich